[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette fois aux
questions stop science pas aux questions
pour lequel j'ai l'honneur d'accueillir
jean le loeuff directeur du musée des
dinosaures d'espéraza et qui va nous
parler aujourd'hui du tyrannosaurus rex
car il vient il a sorti cette année un
livre qui est très justement intitulé
t-rex superstar donc aujourd'hui bien ça
va être une émission c'est notre
émission de noël j'ai envie de dire où
on va parler de la superstar des
dinosaures le tyrannosaurus rex
jean le loeuff bonjour bonjour on va
essayer de faire l'interview en deux
parties la première partie ce sera donc
des questions que j'ai moi même préparé
à partir de voilà deux questions que
j'avais vu passer à droite et à gauche
de questions je me pose moi même et
ensuite deuxième partie ce sera sur les
questions que nous au que nous ont posé
les internautes sur facebook
donc première question et on va
commencer plutôt simple alors
tyrannosaurus rex et à dinosaures qui
est extrêmement particulier j'ai même
envie de dire que c'est une espèce qui
est extrêmement particulière puisque
avec homo sapiens je crois que c'est
l'une des seules espèces dont le public
général connaît à la fois le nom de
genre et le nom d'espèce tyrannosaurus
et rex
ça doit être installée oui effectivement
effectivement diplodocus par exemple peu
de gens simples qui pourrait s'appeler
long bus mais il a une carrière de toute
façon tout à fait particulière pour un
fossile pour un animal disparu depuis 65
millions d'années puisque on s'imagine
que l'on connaît absolument tout de la
vie du
t-rex depuis sont conscients
intellectuelle jusqu'à ces capacités
sexuelles en gros à travers les vidéos
les films à tout ce qu'on a pu voir sur
lui c'est un animal dont on peut se dire
qu'il a totalement échappé à la maîtrise
ou au contrôle des paléontologues se
dire au premier abord ce dont on peut
s'inquiéter
vous même presque s'inquiéter verrons
nous bientôt des dettes des
tyrannosaures vivent dans des par action
ça peut faire partie effectivement des
question qu'on peut se poser
donc cette première question plutôt
simple on entend de différentes
appellations t-rex tyrannosaure
tyrannosaurus rex tyrannosaurus rex
lequel est le bon y en at il un meilleur
que les autres alors le l'officiel ces
terrains aux ruses rex et ça donne en
abrégé thé point rex pour abréger le
monde genre tyrannosaurus est donc en
anglais le thé se prononcent tidou
célèbre t-rex mondialement connu
l'appellation normal c'est x en français
à tyrannosaur en 6 et le le cirrus latin
et puis t-rex c'est aussi accepter pour
presque toutes jeunes et les
appellations possible pour l'animal
l'occuper en parle de la même chose qui
explique l essentiel souvent dans les
médias ce qu'on voit c'est le mot
tyrannosaure employés aussi pour
désigner par exemple das plateau zaurus
albertosaurus on et désignent sous le
grand ensemble des tyrannosaures et y
arrive souvent que dans les
documentaires justement les ses
documentaires joue sur cette ambiguïté
pour faire croire qu'on parle de
tyrannosaurus rex
il ya une confusion mais qu'on classique
jeu les tyrannosaures comme celle et les
autres espèces qui est liée à la
classification puisque les tyrannosaures
pour partie bhl tyrannosaurus ou aspects
théoriques sont comportés de la famille
des tyrannosauridés que l'on peut
appeler ainsi en français on peut dire
les tyrannosauridés mais ont également
dire les tyrannosaures au sens de la
famille des tyrannosauridés voire de sud
et des tyranneaux euro id sens-là
tyrannosaure ça peut vouloir dire
tyrannosaurus ça peut vouloir dire
tyrannosauridés donc une quinzaine de
gens ça peut vouloir dire tirano i dont
qu'une trentaine ou une quarantaine
d'espèces
on va dire que tout dépend du contexte
dans lequel le mot est employé
j'ai constaté que les interlocuteurs ont
locuteurs ont parfois du mal à faire la
différence entre tyrannosaures et tirer
nos oreilles qui ferait par les
tyranneaux horrible et de temps en temps
mais on ne peut pas dire que
tyrannosaure le monde tyrannosaure sont
impropres
oui peut-être pour cette vidéo on va
essayer de quand on parle de t-rex on
m'accuse dire t-rex et quand on parle de
sa famille on peut dire tyrannosaure ou
tyrannosauridés tyrannosauridés c'est le
plus simple et le plus le plus correct
que j'allais vivre et puis on reprend
une petite différence sinon
effectivement bahia ya fatalement une
confusion entre another étirements
les gens nous corrigerons dans les
commentaires de toute façon donc
toujours à propos du nom du tyrannosaure
j'ai vu passer dans la littérature qu'en
fait il devrait s'appeler manosque on
dit luce gigas parce que c'est parce que
c'est vrai ça alors n'est pas
entièrement faux disons que mano ce pont
dit luce c'est un genre qui a été créé
par le célèbre paléontologue américain
coke dans les années 1810 exact en tête
à partir de quel décret pour nommer deux
vertèbres découverte dans le montana
deux vertèbres caudales d'un gros
dinosaure carnivore et qu'en trente ans
plus tard aux sports n'a décrit le genre
tyrannosaurus avec d'autres votre nom de
genre d'ailleurs votre genre de grands
théropodes comme dynamo et il n'a il a
fait remarquer que les vertèbres de pop
était mal conservés peu diagnostic
du coup il ne retenait pas ce nom de
manu et qu' il désignait les squelettes
dessus pompe lait qu'ils avaient sous de
nouveaux noms de joueurs en espèces
alors évidemment la priorité la loi de
priorité en amont la nature fait que en
théorie c'est manos pondi lui ce qui
devrait avoir aucun groupe des six est
effectivement un t-rex
je trouve que l' usage a fait que pour
l'instant personne n'a eu des antilles
culièrement stupide de réactualiser ce
nom de ce nom de genre basé sur un
matériel vraiment pas terrible bagarre à
continuer d'utiliser c'est grâce à
osborn qu'on appelle pas le tyrannosaure
la grosse vertèbres spongieuse du coup
du coup je pense qu'effectivement
personne ne se serait intéressé autant
tyrannosaure en tête s'il avait porté un
bon si ridicule parce que le le nom et
la façon dont on nomme les choses
important on se rencontre dans le monde
nous vivons et d'avoir donné à son bébé
le nom de tyrannosaurus rex 3 des
lézards tyran ça a certainement
contribué à son succès populaire s'était
appelée la petite crevette à nu qui les
a ramenés par exemple ça n'aurait pas eu
le même le même succès c'est le nom qui
fait peur chez les tirs a besoin même le
nom d'ailleurs si on regarde
un petit peu les différents genres de
tyrannosaure on voit qu'ils ont tous des
idées et non créés pour faire peur à
ruelle
lytro nax c'est le roi du dehors des
noms qui sont bien calculé pour pour
terroriser celui qui le nient alors du
coup puisqu'on parle de puisqu'on parle
de l'animal qui inspire la terreur le
débat qui entoure le t-rex en tout cas
car en touraine direct pendant la fin
des années 80 tout les années 90 et qui
elle est qui hante encore l'internet
aujourd'hui prédateurs ou pas etait-il à
sharon yahoo à un grand chasseur serrano
un tyrannosaurus rex en maintenance en
paléontologie on essaye quand il s'agit
d'animaux qui ne représentons actuelle
c'est généralement de se baser sur la
voie dans la nature actuelle pour
proposer des hypothèses
certes fragile la sur l'écologie de ces
de ses bêtes
donc pendant pendant longtemps ce qui a
été dit comme c'est que le tyrannosaure
de tommy montre que c'est juste un
carnivore qui manger la viande
du coup on a quand même la plupart des
auteurs ont quand même supposer que
comme les carnivores actuelle c'est
probablement un opportuniste
imaginez qu'il était qui ne dédaignez
pas une charogne et quand il m'a croisé
évidemment mais qu'il était également
capable de chasser les longtemps quand
même là ils ont l'opinion professée par
la plupart des gens sérieux
après certains ont fait remarquer assez
justement d'ailleurs que le squelette de
tyrannosaurus n'est pas bâtie pour la
course
on voit par exemple et les tidianes en
cours par rapport aux faits murs espagne
autriche pour c'est pas un animal qui
est très pour galoper pour un carnivore
cassé on envoie un animal qui
rattraper cette fois à la course
du coup il ya eu une hypothèse également
anciennement des parce que ça te dit
début du 20e siècle
quant aux bornes à créer tyrannosaurus
lui l'a vu comme après le prédateur
ultime aux chasseurs impitoyable et dans
le même temps y avait un peu notamment
son cher qu'à travailler qui a décrit
goerg aux russes au canada qui lui
interprétait son autre tyrannosauridés
promettant rencontrèrent un être très
beau jeu très lourd sur de gros lézard
qui devaient se déplacer très
difficilement dont il était tout à fait
possible mais uniquement charognards
incapable d'abord chasser ses proies
alors l'hypothèse de lempaut n'a pas eu
beaucoup de succès jusqu'à ce qu'elle
soit vraie activé dans les années 70 80
au moins pour des gens charmants
c'était pas un prédateur c'est s est un
chambre débat qui aurait pu rester
totalement sans fin puisque s'il des
clips au test contre hypothèse mais sans
absolument aucune preuve
continuez à dire mais si c'est un animal
c'est un charognard
il y a aucun argument décisif ni dans un
sens ni dans l'autre ne pouvaient être
apportées et jusqu'à ce qu' il ya trois
ans un chercheur américain ne décrit en
promo du dakota des vertèbres là que
d'un agronome qui était si b comme voix
s'est fâché dans les vertèbres caudales
des dinosaures soudés par un calot
soudées entre elles par un développement
anarchique des choses qui à peine arrivé
après les fractures après les blessures
avec des infections
et au milieu duquel osseuse ce qu'a
montré ce qu'a trouvé de balles mal
c'est qu'il ya une petite pointe dedans
et que cette petite pointe de danse et
une pointe de dans deux autres donc une
là la conclusion quand c'est la preuve
magnifique comme la paléontologie
c'est en réserve est la preuve qu un
tyrannosaure a mordu la drosophile qui
semble indiquer que le tyrannosaure
n'était pas uniquement charognards et
que la droite heures en question a dû
avoir mal comme ça mais qu'il s'en est
sorti de la même guéri puisque son
affection et donc c'est la preuve ultime
et définitive le nom le tyrannosaure
n'était pas seulement en championnat ils
étaient surpresseur est utile aussi
charognards probable après tout les
gardes alors vers le tyrannosaure ça
doit être allée des vertébrés terrestres
dont on a dont on a le plus de traces de
dents sur des sur des ossements imagine
si je me rappelle bien j'avais vu ça
dans le livre de boucau 1990 qui
retraçait un peu toutes les preuves
paléo biologique et ça avait vraiment
l'air d'être celui où il y avait le plus
de tout cas pour les vertébrés
terrestres en face oui il ya beaucoup de
traces de dante un tyrannosaure bon faut
dire que le ouest des états unis à la
fin du crétacé c'est la région du monde
la mieux connue en termes de dinosaures
donc en nombre de dents mon quantité de
matériel c'est la can a le plus dans le
monde
c'est logique les traces de dents de
t-rex j'en ai beaucoup
il y en a sur un peu tout
les autres tyrannosaure également les
matches soient des mâchoires d'autres
c'est vrai que oui c'est pas des eaux
avec des traces de dents on tire nous on
met du coup tant que tant qu'on n'a pas
cette trace comme comme qu'il a expliqué
comme on attend qu'on n'a pas cette
phrase de rssi 4 isation par option peut
pas savoir si l'animal a été tué par la
morsure ou si c'est une morsure post
mortem ça et c'est exactement ce que
j'appelle toutes les autres races sont
faites sur des animaux qui étaient en
train d'être dépassé et il ment pour
d'autres raisons ou tuées par le même
dirais que c'est impossible à dire
la différence c'est que cette dent de
tyrannosaure avec lequel on se montre
que c'était bien sûr mais de maladie ou
qui chassa et tous les autres traces ne
sont pas une preuve définitive sont une
preuve du fait que je dirais que c'est
pas avec un carnivore
peu de gens je pense on sérieusement
remis en question le fait qu'elle est un
carnivore mon pinceau 90 lecture où
certains auraient essayé de le faire
passer pour un idiot mais mais ensuite
voilà ce qui est pratiquement impossible
à démontrer mais pour le tyrannosaure
comme pour tous les autres carnivores
disparu c'est qu'ils aient des chasseurs
allemands c'est impossible la démo ça
fait dire aussi que je ne sais pas moi
je le dis on n'est guère mettait des
cavernes et était uniquement charognards
prouver le contraire
c'est improbable normalement il faut
vraiment trouver le fossile imaginables
pour pouvoir et l'ouest des états unis
est en est capable oui oui oui là
quelque 1 850 m
mais ça existe
puis ce qui est bien c'est que en
paléontologie de temps en temps comme là
la découverte d'un malencontreux
difficile on rend caduque eu toutes
sortes de belz hypothèse que tu
s'échiner à monter pendant des décennies
et à perfectionner et donna groupes ou
chanteurs à mettre aucun cas un relevé
discussions précédentes
puisqu'on parle dans le vide avec ce
prédateur on peut parler de ses proies
alors on a des images épique dans nos
têtes avec des tyrannosaures affrontant
des diplodocus des tyrannosaures
affrontant des stégosaure est ce que est
ce qu'on pourrait remettre un peu en
contexte du coup le pour nos auditeurs
sans parler du tyrannosaure affrontant
un spinosaures bien entendu voilà aussi
mais mais mais mais bien entendu dans
tous les cas cette imagerie et charmante
pour les deux premiers cas en tout cas
n'est pas du tout fondées puisque les
stégosaures la disparition du dernier ce
dégoût taurus et l'apparition des
premiers tyrannosaure 80 millions
d'années donc jamais à tyrannosaur n'a
pu grignoter l'accueil d'un diplodocus
nous on est à 80 minutes 80 millions
d'années ça veut dire que nous sommes
actuellement plus proche du dernier
tyrannosaure que le premier tyrannosaure
n'est plus proche n'est proche du
dernier stage aux orres s'ils ont
vraiment du temporel et évidemment pour
ceux qui c'est la même chose qu'il ait
qui les sépare donc que manger à
tyrannosaur pas forcément les animaux
qui vivaient à la même époque que lui et
au même endroit c'est beaucoup plus
probable d'avoir mangé des animaux
disparus
et pour en savoir plus c'est quoi ces
animaux c'était quoi les dinosaures à la
même époque dans le centre ouest des
états unis
c'était notamment des arroseurs et les
dinosaures avec des formules dont le
fameux tricératops et après pour en
savoir plus bayal les traces de dents
d'une part et puis là quelque chose
d'encore plus une plaisant pour
reconnaître mon régime alimentaire des
tyrannosaures c'est le père est décrit
un coproduit le tyrannosaure il ya déjà
une bonne vingtaine d'années et à
l'intérieur de ce pur produit de
tyrannosaure on a des petits fragments
d'os
parce qu'on peut expliquer ce que c'est
qu'un corps progrès que c'est un kaka
comment on reconnaît à comment on
reconnaît un cas possible de
tyrannosaure commencé que c'est pas
quelqu'un d'autre
c'est là une question en fait on
commence par trouver un cas facile et en
l'occurrence est assez bonne taille ça
fait une quarantaine de centimètres à
quai de cailloux rempli de petits
fragments dans ce bref c'est un produit
des pions jeudi dans la région où on l'a
trouvée qui a pu produire déjà ses
conseils les mines tous les animaux
herbivores carnivores qui s'est beaucoup
trop gros pour un crocodile c'est
beaucoup trop gros pour tous les
déprédateurs connu dans ces formations
l'extrême fin une grotte de tirana une
logique imparable et est donc comme
angers c'est le tyrannosaure on voit on
étudie les petits elle étudie le lait
petit bout d'os on regarde le jeune
cadre aux heures et de jeunes serra
obtient en fait
et donc on en déduit que j'aime avoir eu
des mots et c'est largement
exclusivement en tout cas qu'à son manu
il y avait des skis mais finalement
gigantesque jeu mais qui a le mérite de
démontrer scientifiquement ce qu'on est
capable de dire avec le registre que si
l'actuel s'il était capable de chasser
en groupe ou est ce que c'était un
chasseur solitaire alors il faut bien
l'avouer question je l'appelais ma
conscience évidemment ce genre de
questions devraient normalement le
balayer nos gouvernements gens qui
semblent enfin parce que vous savez déjà
si les ornithorynques que dans la nature
actuelle chez stands en bande organisée
comment voulez vous qu'on répondre à la
même question sur l'animal qui a disparu
il ya 65 millions d'années
c'est ce que l'on devrait dire
normalement mais les paléontologues sont
obstinés ce pont et est ingénieux et
donc oui on peut répondre envisager de
répondre à la question des lits froids
de tyrannosaurus rex mais d'un de ses
proches cousins du crétacé supérieur
colombie-britannique dont on a retrouvé
les traces de pas fossilisées cm de
l'onj fêteront des grosses crasse donc
au pied de pas très utilisé
rien n'a très peu des empreintes de pas
fossilisées le tyrannosaure pour
l'instant trouvé quelques unes des
dernières années et ce site de
colombie-britannique son intérêt c'est
pas très très grand il a même d'ailleurs
donc il a disparu sous une halle et demi
mais ce qu'on a ce qu'on trouve qu'on
trouvait les chercheurs qui ont bossé là
dessus c'est en fait la présence de
trois pistes parallèles aux
tyrannosaures donc a priori de trois
animaux adultes qui se déplaçaient
ensemble dans la même direction
donc c'est une des rares erreurs
éléments qu'on est qu'il laisse supposer
que les tyrannosaures avait une vie
sociale
alors est-ce que ça allait jusqu'à
chasser ensemble montée des enfants
fiscale etc ça on ne le sait pas pour
l'instant improbable mais ce qui
comptera ce qu'on a pu aussi bien les
grands garmin en solitaire c est beau
avec une vie sociale
il veut sinon aux ordres de du moins en
groupe on a des empreintes du coup est
ce qu'on est capable de mesurer la
vitesse à laquelle il pouvait se déplace
oui mais oui mais comme souvent avec les
enfants c'est assez décevant parce que
dans le sens qu'on connaît qu'on va en
avoir beaucoup pour mon empreinte de pas
de dinosaures il ya quasiment aucune de
dinosaures au galop donc c'est toujours
des animaux qui se déplace en fait ou
pas quelques quelques kilomètres heure
rien de rien de bien impressionnant mais
une piste de tyrannosaure au galop sera
peut-être un jour quand on entend dire
que tyrannosaure vais courir plus vite
moins vite qu'un homme ou des choses
comme ça ça se passe sur quoi ces
déclarations prévues comme moi la trappe
presqu'une le jeep lancé à pleine
vitesse le terrain on se dira qui
courait vite c'était une piste de terre
la ville devait aller relativement
lentement
comment comment calculer la vitesse on
réussit et là on ne sait pas trop il ya
des modèles des pensions en pâtit le
calculer la vitesse maximale en fonction
de la longueur des différents segments
des bateaux mais ils ont pu entacher au
minimum
beaucoup d'incertitudes une très très
grosse marge d'erreur ne calculent
qu'ils évoquent un tyrannosaure la vie à
40 à l'heure ce n'est pas absurde
[Musique]
la seule preuve définitive une piste de
bronze il nous en carnivores comme ça
donc c'est un appel à c'est un appel aux
jeunes générations qui nous écoutent
il reste encore des choses à savoir sur
le t-rex et reste des choses à découvrir
et énormément brume en partie d'accord
juste puisqu'on est sur la biologie du
tyrannosaure du coup là je pense que la
deuxième grande question que tout le
monde se pose après est-ce que c'était
un prédateur ou passer à quoi devait lui
servir ses petits bras
si jamais il servait à quelque chose
cependant si jamais il servi à quelque
chose en effet sont là plus la plus
pratique de répondre à la question
il ne lui servait à rien il est inutile
de se poser la question
puis quand on regarde la saison avec
zéro quand on regarde les oiseaux
actuels il chasse très bien sans arbre à
tout à fait huer le de toute façon la
question n'est pas fini est-ce que
c'était en fait de la question c'est
plutôt est-ce que c'était des organes en
voie de régression qui n'est plus tard
another gc recommande par exemple
complètement intérieur ou bien est ce
que savait une
une fonction que ça lui servait à
quelque chose à bord n'avait pu
décrocher copulatoire au moment du plan
il ya eu un compte twitter est là bien
sûr conserver les pattes on va tous que
le direct foot à faire avec et donc on
est on est on obligé de constater que
c'est désespérant pour les malheureux on
relevé il ya une vie difficile qui
doivent être fatigué de temps en temps
chez teal dormir quelques heures
et quand il fallait se relever d'après
certains collègues ont été très pratique
avec pat donc s'appuyer dessus un peu
comme en sprint heures quand il démarre
en s'appuyant sur ses opposants sur sept
sur sept mois donc peut-être peut-être
il ya une étude en cours en ce moment
sur les bras du squelette du
tyrannosaure du muséum de chicago elle
passait à l'intérieur et dit je crois
les serait peut-être on supposait mais
aucune idée que tu ça servait à quelque
chose
ils ont déterminé sans partir de la
texture interne à partir de la densité
c'est ça mais c'était juste j'ai une
annonce que j'ai vu il ya quelques
semaines mel publication est annoncée
pour dans constitue séduit partage bon
goût qui tue donc pour l'instant
peut-être peut-être bientôt des
des révélations parce que par exemple on
secrètes sur les russes y avait des
muscles inséré dessus plus mais voilà et
du tyrannosaurus à le tout-petit braves
il ya d'autres espèces qu'il y avait
aussi les tout petits bras comme ça car
moto rue cependant admis lausanne à
belize grande famille de dinosaures
d'argentine c'est une tendance chez
l'évolution des différentes familles de
très gros prédateur d'avoir les bras
[Musique]
c'est lié au développement de la
mâchoire la mâchoire devient tellement
imposante on peut le supposer
on peut en voir une corrélation aux
mâchoires effectivement et puis là la
diminution de la taille encore une autre
question qui revient très souvent la
présence de plumes
je crois je crois savoir donc qu'on n'a
pas d'empreintes de pau pour
tyrannosaurus rex
alors peut-être peut-être une ou deux
quand même une deux sur je sais plus
quel squelette re découvrir récemment
mais c'est des domaines du centimètre
carré de quelques centimètre carré de
peau écailleuse est pareil à sur tarbes
aux russes jeu contient un peu plus il
ya des fragments de propane ronchaud
centimètre carré ou dizaine de
centimètres carrés avec pareil une
bouille cagnotte
carbo aux russes c'est le pendant
asiatique de tyrannosaures et ça c'est
le plus proche cousin de tyrannosaurus
rex qui vivait en mongolie le
tyrannosaure dont le tyrannosaure de
nicholas cage il a dû rendre comme un
certain nombre d'autres squelettes de
tarbes aux russes du congo tous les
squelettes de tarbes où j'ai vu ce qu'on
a vu en grande quantité sur des salles
des ventes ces dernières années ont été
sortis illégalement donc tout devrait
normalement y retourner c'est parce que
donc les tyrannosaurus rex c'est
vraiment juste d'imiter l'ouest amérique
du nord ce n'est même pas même la glace
et l'eau le montana les dakota extrême
sud du canada mais c'est vraiment une
toute petite région de l'ouest américain
et pendant une période de temps très
bref c'est vraiment c'est le maastricht
hier supérieur c'est les deux trois
derniers millions d'années de d'accord
alors c'était quoi les prédateurs à
l'est des états unis
il y avait cette espèce d'océan cette
mer intérieure il y avait une mer
intérieure tout à fait à la fin on ne
connaît pas très très bien
[Musique]
la faune est est américaine de la côte
est vers la fin du crétacé
mais avant la fin du crétacé il ya aussi
des tyrannosaures aux ide
en dans la partie orientale des états
unis après l'extrême fin du crétacé
c'est très très méconnue par rapport à
la partie occidentale dont on sait qu'il
ya des à brothers il ya un carnivore qui
s'appelle au visage unités ont été
discutés ils sont pas forcément résolue
mais n'est pas de tyrannosaurus ont donc
tyrannosaure e id c'est là c'est
l'ensemble au dessus des tyrannosauridés
c'est ça c'est ça y est me sens plus
affilié au tyrannosauridés qu'à d'autres
group sa est donc là alors autant chez
les tyrannosauridés d'ailleurs
tyrannosaurus tarbes aux russes on a des
traces des cayes mais pas de plumes
autant chez les tyrannosaures aux ide là
si je crois me souvenir
on a trouvé les traces de plus près il
ya une ou deux tirano euro id asiatiques
qui ont des plumes des trucs assez
primitif bon alors qu'ils n'ont pas non
plus la même préservation c'est sûr on
espère et en plaques en 3d donc les
squelettes à plaques c'est super joli
lui mais sont pas forcément faciles à
étudier et à comparer non plus
donc le statut phylogénétique précis de
toutes ses formes peu de beaucoup
évoluer en fonction des études à venir
certaines bestioles sont actuellement
classés dans les tyrannosaures onid faut
pas beaucoup de caractère pour que ça
passe d'un groupe à côté il n'est pas
encore évident aujourd'hui que des
tyrannosaures or il était découvert vos
pulls même si d'un point de vue
philosophique éthique c'est probable
puisque la présence de crâne est revendu
plus tôt plus on monte à des aléas des
groupes us archaïque que les tirs amis
donc on peut d'un point de vue
philosophique éthique on regardera un
arbre phylogénétique avec les groupes
qui ont des plumes
quand on est sûr qu'ils ont déplu mais
ceux pour lesquels on se pose la
question il est fort probable que les
tyrannosaures et eu pour ancêtre des
animaux a plus d'accord et il est blanc
qu'il l'était après ans l'absence de
preuves ce n'est pas une preuve de
l'absence comme chacun sait donc donc
les tyrannosaures s'ils ont eu des
ancêtres avec des plumes les avait-il
perdu dans l'évolution ou bien en fait
aidé et il couvert depuis certains
endroits du corps ou non la plupart des
représentations c'est un tyrannosaure
ont leur bois des des plumes sur les
pattes antérieures justement où et c'est
un petit peu partout et puis des
écailles sur le reste du corps
une hypothèse qui est phylogénétiquement
fondée mais voilà bon c'est une c'est
pas le liaoning le pays du tyrannosaure
c'est pas un endroit où l'est les
squelettes entiers avec les parties
molles sont également conservés
on ne s'attend pas à ce que cette
question trouve une réponse dans un
avenir proche et lointain et non d'après
bon il ya quand même au canada ces
nombres
momy entre guillemets dan rose or si un
jour on tombe sur sur l'équivalent en
tyrannosauridés en tout cas bien avant
c'est le jeu que j'aime mais c'est là je
crois que il ya nos auditeurs qui sont
en train de rêver là deux sont en train
de rêver de momies de tyrannosaures et
mon papa il ya des bons nombre d'adrs
rosoor préservé avec leur logeuse
cependant certains gisements de mongolie
d'ailleurs houdan ou dans des sites
canadiens qui en point me meyer de
ressembler la po dea brothers
c'est ce que l'attention que je connais
depuis le début du 20e siècle m donc
pourquoi pas c'est systématiquement des
as droz à pas de chance un jour un terme
aux heures et dans les mêmes conditions
aller beaucoup plus loin alors selon qui
est présence ou absence de plumes du
coup ça ferait le j'imagine basculer un
peu le débat sur avait t-il le sang
chaud le sang froid
roh non pas vraiment parce que là il est
allé dire le débat année a été réglée
d'une autre manière
sur les isotopes de l'oxygène
donc tu loues pas plus à ça en fait ça
change grand chose c'est cette histoire
que probable actuellement c'est que le
métabolisme des dinosaures était plus
proche de celui des manies faire que
celui des reptiles contemporain bon les
tyrannosaures il était très probablement
également à son show je sais pas si on a
german denis là dessus a précédemment
échantillonnés les dents de tyrannosaure
sur les dents le dinosaure en général
résultat les enfants c'est sensé clair
la méthode des jeunes chimistes qui
permet d'avoir une idée
de la température du corps de l'animal
au moment où on forme les tissus le sud
et dans ne semble ces dernières années
[Musique]
des monstres et ou en tout cas fait
nettement peut être se poser pencher la
balance
d'accord il ya ça il ya aussi la courbe
de croissance je crois qu'il est très
impressionnante de t-rex et qui
suggèrent qu'ils avaient le sang chaud
c'est ça ouais c'est très vite
effectivement il mourrait jeunes puisque
les plus gros spécimens sont 24 au 28
ans d'après le l'histologie désolant
après le fait de grandir très vite aussi
je suis pas sûr que ce soit directement
un métabolisme de type sang chaud et les
petits crocodiles grandissent très vite
aussi je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient une
relation directe
ah ça c'est peut-être une question qui
n'aura pas de réponse niveau
comportement de ponte soit parentaux
est-ce qu'on a des indices chez t-rex on
ne connaît pas 2 de terrain mais on ne
connaît pas non plus de jeunes
d'embryons donc aucune simplement là où
on ne connaît pas pour l'instant on n'a
pas trouvé de fossiles permettant de
répondre à ces questions
même les je vais juvénile d'utiliser des
juvéniles de t-rex les adolescents
direct ce lien des bois puisque tyrannus
qui est contemporain de tyrannosaurus
qui est en tyrannosaure
qui pour certains est un autre genre des
brasiers gif états unis actuellement
mais deux temps une cible il ya une
partie du matériel qui permettrait de
répondre à ces questions là qui est dans
des collections du diable par les
chercheurs en suspendant la tente
toujours de nouvelles décos d'accord
comment on pourrait tester s'il s'agit
d'un juvénile ou pas entre autres par
par l'histologie mais c'est pas mal
d'avoir mieux d'avoir puisqu'un seul
d'un seul squelette le jeudi on a
souvent ce problème c'est qu'on a des
échantillons notoirement trop faible
pour pouvoir répondre à un certain
nombre de questions
il s'agit de la croissance d'un
dinosaure quand il s'agit de dimorphisme
sexuel on a généralement de matériel
suffisamment abondante pour pouvoir
répondre de manière claire et la
question d'accord donc la question de
nano tyrannus reste en suspens oui oui
elle l'est toujours mais pour ce qui est
des comportements reproducteurs javel
avait vu passer que chez les
tyrannosaures un peu trash eh oui chez
les tyrannosaures un peu comme celle et
les rapaces actuelle c'est les femelles
qui sont plus grosses que les mâles
c'est ça ces hypothèses en vogue
actuellement
si elle vient d'être réfutées pour des
raisons statistiques que je n'ai pas mon
concours une semaine j'ai vu passer un
article
expliquer justement que les échantillons
ou les méthodes statistiques utilisées
opérationnel mais si l'on accepte cette
récente de contradictions on a
effectivement d'après certains
chercheurs américains vraiment 2d
morphotype chez l'esplanade de tirer
d'abord connu un qui est plus trapu
l'autre qui est plus gracile et dans les
eaux des squelettes les plus d'un des
squelettes les plus populaires qui a mis
en évidence en types de tissus aux jeux
qui serait de l'os médullaire c'est à
dire le petit pot ce qu'on trouve chez
les oiseaux avant la pause
donc je mets loison les fuméloises
repompe du calcaire de leur zoo pour
fabriquer leur sésame j'utilise pour ça
un type d'os qui est qui se stockent
encore de lancer le même type de tissu
donc auraient été identifiés cette
chercheuse dans un os tyrannosaure de la
forme robuste alors on soupçonnait déjà
que la forme robuste et et la femelle
parce que il ya davantage d'écart entre
sion et la queue chez ses décibels
robuste et gracile ce qu'ils valent
laissera plus de place aux demandes la
ponte b2c un espace entre le bassin et
le bord inférieur de la queue et il
serait penché les femelles pour que
l'homme puisse sortir donc cette
accumulation de d'éléments fait qu'en ce
moment on pense en effet à dimanche 8
mai sexuel chez qui ressort si les
statisticiens n'ont pas l'air d'accord
voilà
nonobstant cesser ces réclamations qui
peut être son fond d'elles serait engagé
il semble que le tyrannosaure soit la
seule miss rex la seule espèce de
dinosaure aujourd'hui
chez lequel on peut reconnaître le mal
de la faune et ça c'est déjà
extraordinaire c'est déjà merveilleux et
mais ça montre l'intérêt que l'on porte
à cet animal parce que bon il ya
d'autres dinosaures qui sont connues par
plus d'un squelette mais on n'a jamais
poussé les investigations aussi loin
dans toutes ses autres moi parce que si
vous montrer qu'il ya de l'os médullaire
je ne sais pas c'est un peu donc par
exemple chez la forme de gracefield
europe 2 vous faites jamais netscher ça
n'intéressera personne alors que cissé
dans l'os du t-rex lecture dire je ne
sais plus peu importe mais c'est quelque
chose qui forcément va avoir des
retombées elle va passer dans une revue
prestigieuse et c'est toujours mieux
faire ce genre ok je suis un t-rex que
je suis ton chaud donc puisqu'on parle
d'interaction mâle femelle chez les
dinosaures qui a été l'auteur d'un
article qui m'a beaucoup plu qui qui
était en fait le résumé le résumé d'une
étude faite à propos des cris des
dinosaures de l'évolution du cirac ce
crochet chez les dinosaures et les
oiseaux qui était sur ton sur le dino
blog d'ailleurs j'ai oublié de le dire
tout à l'heure mais tu est aussi
l'auteur de l'article de vulgarisation
scientifique sur ledit nos blogs sont de
très bonne qualité j'encourage tout le
monde à aller visiter le dino blog et il
y en a 1 donc sur la dessus sur
l'évolution du cirac ce donc d'où ma
question
le cri du tyrannosaure et est il capable
de chanter pour attirer sa belle bah
alors je ne me souviens plus trop ce que
j'ai écrit sur ces passionnantes objets
surnaturels mais mais j'ai bien peur que
pour le tyrannosaure l'instant on n'est
pas la moindre idée de la nature de ces
éventuelles vocalises
donc j c'est in you let in on ne sait
pas oui pour vega vice pour le crétacé
qui était l'objet de cette étude du coup
c'est l'été les contenir
alors là j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
depuis que j'écris cette chose là je
crois que j'avais oublié le détail ce
qui est impressionnant chez vega vice
c'est que les équipes qui a travaillé là
dessus a retrouvé fossilisés donc ce ce
petit organe ces minuscules se disent
ceux généralement pas et qui permet la
localisation chez les oiseaux je ne
crois pas cependant qu'ils ont réussi à
me faire chanter à nouveau et oiseau
disparu depuis que l'état s'est lui même
et peut-être pourrait-il qu'il cherchait
à faire quelque chose en tout cas chez
les dinosaures non aviens un stand
connaît pas de syrinx saucisses d'accord
donc est-ce qu'on a d'autres indicateurs
qui permettrait au moins d'avoir une
vague idée est ce qu'ils avaient des
cordes vocales est ce qu'il avait on
sait pas cependant on ne s'est pas
franchement le cri du dinosaure pour
l'instant ça fait encore partie des
choses qui sont un petit peu en la
demeure
possibilité technique de c'est tout ce
que j'ai écrit sur ce sujet j'ai
complètement oublié mon histoire de
syrinx c'est pas grave je mettrais un
lien description les gens iront voir ça
leur donnera une bonne occasion d'aller
voir le dino blog c'est quelque chose je
suis régulièrement
suis je suis grand fan d'ailleurs depuis
ce qu'on parle du dino blog ce qu'on
peut être justement à ce qu'on peut en
parler un petit peu comment comment ça
tu es venu de vouloir créer ce blog de
sur internet pour pourquoi écrire sur
internet pour les pour les gens plus que
d'écrire des projets scientifiques pour
le plaisir déjà de décrire puis d'écrire
sur un point tout à fait dans un tout
autre registre celui des questions
scientifiques et pouvoir aborder des
tous les thèmes que l'on souhaite et
déjà fait pas mal décrit de
vulgarisation avant mais c'est
généralement delà de la commande
le sujet est bon et c'est pas très
marrant donc là ça permet de canton
attentat sur de réagir sur sur
l'actualité et de donner un point de vue
qui soit à qui soit surtout pas
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on essaye celui
d'un compte rendu
on peut dire dans une agence de presse
étrille en cas de l'université kent ces
chercheurs a fait une découverte
fondamentale est fantastique qui
révolutionne la science c'est de pouvoir
donner le point de vue de qualité
paléontologues je suis en actualité pas
disciplinés puis de préférence d'un
manière un peu décalée
préférant ceci sans se prendre trop au
sérieux
une théologie bien entendu une
discipline extrêmement sérieuse mais ce
n'est pas une raison pour se morfondre
dans temps en temps on parle quand on
écrit à 100 à son sujet donc c'était
vraiment une idée la volonté d'avoir un
espace de liberté avec un ton différent
pour parler de parler et donc mais dont
claudine au blog après allait très bien
bourbon parme était aussi une bonne
visibilité sur internet pour le musée
des dinosaures mais c'est ça voilà c'est
la notion de plaisir et d'amusement et
conséquente est bon les raisons de
l'existence de ce blog continue ainsi
les célèbres bientôt célèbre rencontre
au bout mais jamais eu lieu à deux
reprises et qui rassemble autour d'un
cassoulet et de quelques blagues
les lecteurs du dino blog tous les
premier week-end de juillet et de
quelques conférences canton cavier aux
amateurs de cassoulet et de dinosaures
et de et de blagues paléontologie c'est
d'avoir b des conférences qui soit aussi
un petit peu différente de celle bien
plus vous couvrez un large panel de
sujets enfin par exemple un sujet qui a
fait très rarement abordé dans la
littérature francophone c'est la crypte
de l'ovi hausse mais disons que pour
dire que historiquement les pieds pas
mal de paléontologues français qui se
sont bien intéresser à la cryptologie
qui ont plutôt défendu zoologie je pense
à pascal tassy eric buffetaut michelle
martin qui depuis les années 70 montrent
un intérêt chez dirais que c'est presque
classique en france pour les
paléontologues de ne pas cracher
sur sur l'ensemble la crypte juifs qui
relève davantage de la poésie de la
science mais il ya aussi donc il ya po
il ya aussi même pour ceux qui sont pas
spécialement gaga des dinosaures il ya
aussi donc lionel authier jean louis art
en berger qui qui écrivent à propos des
mammifères la plume de la plume de jean
louis attend berger par ailleurs tout à
fait particulière est recommandé à tous
calibres est là et il ya beaucoup de
lionel cavin si je ne me trompe pas qui
sait malgré moi que tu pourras être
calqué sur les pressions dont on
comprend donc il y en a pour qui adore
les fossiles vivants
j'adore les fossiles comme en reparler
de facile en grand dam d'un certain
nombre d' habiller le gist qui trouve
qu'on devrait pas parler que je suis on
a eu bien parler du possible et c'est
une des rares fois où on parle de
fossiles absolument exigent en plus si
c'est pas merveilleux
franchement si c'est là quand tu n'es
pas en considérant qu'ils n'ont pas
rentré dans ses douloureux débat
je crois que c'était le petit hors sujet
à propos du dîner blog
allez le voir voilà avec une chose à
retenir c'est allé le voir justement
possible vivants ont retransmis sione
vers le t-rex possible vivant on en
parlait tout à l'heure
résurrection du t-rex point
d'interrogation
forte heureusement au programme dont on
peut retrouver l'adn dans des glaces
très récent les molécules fragile du
tyrannosaure et de ses contemporains
dont probablement pas survécu jusqu'à
nous ont vraiment des truites moment de
la pollinisation
ce qui probablement parce que je suis
prudent on a des circonstances
extraordinaires un jour mais donc
normalement ça devrait éviter de pouvoir
reprendre neuf de tyrannosaures et pire
encore d'essayer de le faire éclore
alors
certains cherchent est actuellement une
autre je suis vite une autre démarche
on essaye de faire de faire régresser
les poulets en bidouillant des
génétiquement des ingrédients qui l'est
c'est la culture carnivores c'est dans
ces cas les militaires ont finalement je
ressens très sérieux c'est le projet du
sénat aux russes de jack horner ne croit
qu'à s'occuper semble aussi ladino
poésie oui oui comment ils vivent leur
vie
mais bon tu cette version ne donnera pas
véritable dinosaure on peut
effectivement revivre quelques
caractères de dinosaures carnivores chez
les plaies mais je ne pense pas que ce
soit une piste de recherche très sérieux
et quand même notable je crois que enfin
c'était une séquence était il ya deux
ans trois ans peut-être où on a retrouvé
je crois que c'est le tyrannosaure c'est
un des rares dinosaures pour lequel on a
retrouvé des protéines et des globules
rouges fossilisé par les protéines
justement n'était pas cotisé il y avait
encore des fragments la nouveauté un peu
en dehors de même violon d'ingres et
actuel les eaux bien sec
mais pour ce qu'il ya c'est que c'est le
petit problème avec ces histoires de
protéines globules rouges et c'est que
c'est une bonne quinzaine ou une
vingtaine d'années on en entend parler
de ces histoires là c'est toujours la
même équipe
il annonce avoir trouvé ce genre de
choses mais qu' aucune autre équipe
scientifique dans le monde n'a jamais pu
reproduire ce genre d'expérience ça
permet ni même de poser des questions
sur la validité des résultats vient de
raisons pour gentiment contaminés c'est
bizarre que personne ne réussisse à
reproduire vraiment son genre ce genre
d'expérience donc je suis pas sûr qu'on
puisse dire que c'est démontrer
définitivement la présence comme ça chez
chez un tyrannosaure je reste sceptique
tant que d'autres équipes ne ne
reproduisent pas ça se souvient que
jeune mais pendant l'été 93 qui ne nous
rajeunit pas c'était la sortie de
jurassic park aux états unis au mois de
juin et puis scienti metcher en juillet
on dit a bien annoncé la découverte
d'adn fossilisé dans des insectes
fossiles vieux de 135 millions d'années
et truc formidable c'était jurassic park
pour demain bon c'était pas de l'adn de
dinosaure dans un moustique c'est
annabelle de charenton et quelques
années plus tard une petite réputation
contamination donc on peut se tromper
mais que ce qui est mais il ya des mg
protéines où il ya une certaine méfiance
par rapport à ça parce qu'il ya eu des
précédents où on s'est trompé et des
décors faut pas reproduire aux personnes
ouais je reste sinon sceptiques de moi
prudent mais mais c'est vrai que de plus
en plus on commence à chercher des
choses on les fossiles de dinosaures
qu'on cherchait pas cherchez pas il ya
dix ans je pense mais là non plus
ces dinosaures qui connaissent d'avoir
une idée sans goût de la couleur des
dinosaures c'est des choses
cinquante six ans ces travaux là et
c'est nouveau c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne cherchait même pas avant pensez pas
pouvoir trouver des traces de biologique
on et fossiles de dinosaures mélanosomes
salue ces petits organismes en fait
fossilisés ce n'est plus la matière
organique de départ que l'on retrouve
ses formes du mélanosomes qui est
conservé mais c'est remplacer par une
molécule de départ sont remplacés par
mais c'est les premières années où on
commence un peu à les voir s'ils
auraient donc c'est encore prématuré
pour savoir jusqu'où on va pouvoir aller
là dedans mais peut-être peut-être pas
loin peut-être loin alors passe
maintenant à la deuxième partie de cette
interview donc les questions des
auditeurs
trois questions seulement donc ça
devrait devrait s'en sortir assez vite
première question de julien d'hui qui
est un qui est historien et qui du coup
nous pose une question sur l'histoire
des sciences
sa question est la suivante comment le
t-rex at il acquis son statut de roi des
dinosaures ou chez tui c'est une
question il acquis déjà un moment que
son baptême puisque tyrannosaurus rex
endroit donc statut de roi des
dinosaures de son baptême par par
osbourne
et sa popularité a suivi de peu son
baptême le matériel découvert était
impressionnant de squelettes sub entier
qui ont été montés à l'american museum
de new york pendant la première guerre
mondiale
donc la peau de temps et sur un autre
russe est devenu déjà un héros de
littérature de science fiction sous la
plume d'edgar rice burroughs dans les
années 1916 1917
c'est l'auteur de tarzan le propos
d'argent mais il est également l'auteur
de pas mal d'histoires de sfr par
exemple mais également et lucide est
requis ainsi que deux romans qui se
déroule au centre de la terre qui est
creux et du bifff des survivants une
odeur donc un tyrannosaure donc d'elbe
et les années 10 ça devient un héros de
littérature sera légué par tous les tous
les grands auteurs américains de mai
cette nouvelle avec et ça ça vient du
talent de communication de osbourne
ouais ouais ça ça a bien pris des peurs
et puis ça cesse a compté et puis le
fait que parce c'était effectivement le
plus gros qu'un niveau intéressant ça
évidemment frappé les romanciers les
cinéastes d'aider le king kong de 1933
[Musique]
castagne avait un grand dinosaure
carnivore qui est à l'exposition
universelle de chicago à 134 il y avait
un animatroniques tyrannosaure très vite
c'est un animal qui rencontre un succès
formidable et je sais qu'il deviendra
vraiment mondial avec les efforts
méritoires
avec jurassic park depuis cette une
c'est une star mondiale de tyrannosaure
je vais chez les inuits
là aussi on a très tôt mais comment donc
donc voilà c'est une déjà vieille
histoire
deuxième du t-rex deuxième question
david cappelaere qui nous demandent
alors c'est une question que on a déjà
en partie répond ni à déjà en partie
répondu donc je pense que ça va aller
vite donc le le nano tyrannosaure donc
je suppose qu'ils parlent de nano
tyrannie granit est il un juvénile ou un
animal différent
je crois que la plupart des gens qui
travaillent directement sur les rides et
penchent pour la première hypothèse
et il ya un certain nombre continue dans
le placard s'ils en sortent par
micro-ondes répondront sans dit
clairement à la question confère confère
quelques minutes plus tôt oui voilà
développe sur cette question d'accord et
dernière question d'un à question de nos
auditeurs cyprien brice le t-rex
était-il réellement attiré par la
lumière
déjà il va falloir établir d'où vient
l'idée qu'il est attiré par la lumière
vient je pense que ça vient du premier
jurassic park où la lumière ou le
mouvement je ne sais plus pour essayer
un moment il a dû allumer une torche
mais il essaie de la tienne en fait
c'est le mouvement de la torche et je
crois qu'ils n'attirent voilà voilà
voilà
eh bien nous n'en savons pas plus sur la
pétanque du tyrannosaure pour la ligne
aile et les animaux qui aujourd'hui sont
attirés par le mouvement sont simplement
attiré jeudi ils voient les choses c'est
juste que les mouvements capter leur
attention
oui je rappelle que ce qu'ils
cherchaient je rappelle que c'est du
cinéma que tout cela est né de
l'imagination débridée de crichton mais
de quelques autres il n'y a pas le début
du commencement d'un élément de preuve
scientifique concernant les rapports
entre une lumière vie si on peut
discuter rapidement d'essence chez le
tyrannosaure donc il me semble que pour
la vue on parle d'une vision qui
seraient éventuellement binoculaire si
oui d'un odorat très bien développé un
cerveau normal pour un dinosaure
carnivore de cette taille là en fait
relativement développée avec parmi les
sens peut-être l'odorat particulièrement
ensuite de très vastes cavité en avant
d'un nom du cerveau qui doit être
remplie de tissus épithéliales des de
saisir un peu toutes les molécules
d'odeurs un nez à nez ok très bien
bon bah merci beaucoup jean le loeuff
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ça a été un réel plaisir et un réel
honneur d'accueillir sur notre émission
à un petit mot de la fin peut-être un
petit bout de la fob bonbons succès à
cette option c'est beaucoup d'heures de
futurs jeux vidéo comme pour tous ceux
qui souhaitent en savoir plus nous
recommandons bien sûr la lecture de
t-rex superstar le dernier livre de jean
le loeuff nous recommandons aussi la
lecture dudit nos blogs et le suivi
régulier du dino blog qui commente
l'actualité paléontologique qu'elle soit
dinosaur yen mais aussi de tous les
autres vertébrés en général et pour ceux
qui auraient la flemme de lire
éventuellement iliad à la conférence
qu'a donné jean le loeuff à l'université
de genève genève tout récemment et qui
qui traitent du même sujet donc voilà
tout un tas de contenus qui raviront les
les amateurs de tyrannosauridés donc
encore une fois merci jean le loeuff
nous sommes ici merci et et joyeux noël
très bien dit joyeux noël à tous et à
très bientôt sur stop science
[Musique]